hello uh it's Yannick from the future AI
is moving Crazy Fast right now like
crazy so the news of this week is like
old news but I'm still gonna show to you
Google I O just recently happened the
gist of it is they're gonna stick
generative AI into just about everything
and also anthropic releases upgrades the
Claude API to have a hundred thousand
tokens context no one knows so far how
they're doing it but it's happening a
hundred thousand tokens context insane
all right enjoy the news yay Jeff Hinton
leaves Google and tells the world about
the dangers of AI open AI loses half a
billion dollars and Google has no moat
welcome to ml news
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to ml news let's
Dive Right In lots of stuff happening
this is Snapchat
I do you have access to my location no I
don't have access to your location where
am I I'm sorry but I don't have access
to your location information okay are
you lying no I'm not lying I don't have
access to your location information
where's the closest McDonald's yeah
there's a McDonald's very close to you
it's located right on Young Street in
Tonawanda make of that as you will Jeff
Hinton leaves Google and warns of a
danger ahead this is a story from the
New York Times Jeff Hinton obviously
Pioneer in the field of deep learning
very very early contributor of many of
the currently still used techniques also
one of The Originators of alexnet has
left his long held job at Google and is
now essentially saying that these
Technologies are dangerous and we should
pay attention or stop or just be very
careful of what we do the article says a
part of him he said now regrets his
life's work I console myself with the
normal excuse if I hadn't done it
somebody else would have Dr Hinton said
during a lengthy interview last week in
the dining room of his home in Toronto
it's hard to see how you can prevent the
Bad actors from using it for bad things
Dr Hinton says he says look at how it
was five years ago and how it is now he
said of AI technology take the
difference and propagate it forwards
that's scary until last year he said
Google acted as a proper Steward for the
technology careful not to release
something that might cause harm but now
that Microsoft has augmented its Bing
search engine with a chatbot challenge
in Google's Core Business Google is
racing to deploy the same kind of
Technology the tech Giants are locked in
a competition that might be impossible
to stop Dr Hinton said his immediate
concern is that the internet will be
flooded with false photos videos and
text and the average person will not be
able to know what is true anymore he
also worried that AI technologies will
in time append the job market today chat
Bots like chat gbt tend to complement
human workers but they could replace
paralegal's personal assistant
translators and others who handle wrote
tasks it takes away The Drudge work he
said it might take away more than that
down the road he is worried that future
versions of the technology pose a threat
to humanity because they often learn
unexpected behavior from the vast
amounts of data they analyze this
becomes an issue he said as individuals
and companies allow AI systems not only
to generate their own computer code but
actually run that code on their own and
he fears a day when truly autonomous
weapons those Killer Robots become
reality the idea that this stuff could
actually get smarter than people a few
people believed that he said but most
people thought it was way off and I
thought it was way off I thought it was
30 to 50 years or even longer away
obviously I no longer think that okay
there's obviously a lot being said right
here and Jeff Hinton is certainly a
credible and notable voice to listen to
when it comes to these things but a lot
of people also disagree with him
especially as he sounds more and more
like a foamer for example saying we're
all in the same boat with respect to the
existential threat so we all ought to be
able to cooperate on trying to stop it
and more John Lacon on the other hand
says AI hype is ridiculous in all
directions as in llm have superhuman
intelligence our useless parrots
hallucinations will destroy Society
scaling is all you need deep learning
has hit a wall air doesn't exist and
never will or AI is going to kill us all
I think among the various opinions you
can probably find some common ground but
I also tend to be more on the side of
the car here than of Hinton I don't
think this is that much of an
existential Threat by itself certainly
my biggest fear of this technology is
what happens when it is concentrated in
just a small amount of people like large
companies and governments and what then
happens if people with not so good
intentions come to power in these places
I think that's why they're push to do
open source and to really democratize
this technology is so important that
exactly that doesn't happen the fact
that the internet's going to be flood
with texts that you don't know is true
or not or photos or videos I mean that's
already the situation who cares if you
can generate like 10 000 fake news
articles the problem is distribution the
problem isn't generation I can generate
something fake text right now whatever
let's go okay uh
pineapple eat your remote I I meant to
write ananas do you know the amount of
time it took me to find out that ananas
which is the German word for pineapple
isn't an English word because it sounds
so English
pineapple does not belong on pizza but
this is definitely misinformation I'm
sorry if you agree with this there is no
you make you may be an AI okay I have
now generated Mission formation and I
did not need a language model to do it
so
um you know and yes some people may lose
their jobs and a lot of people's jobs
are going to be transformed but it's not
going to cause mass unemployment it's
just like the Chariot driver that had
now to do something else some people
will have to do something else and
that's okay but of course who wants to
hear from Jeff Hinton or Jan Le Carr one
we can actually listen to the true
expert on the matter obviously Snoop
Dogg has an opinion on this listen like
man this thing can hold a real
conversation like for real for real like
it's it's blowing my mind because I
watch movies on this as a kid years ago
when I used to see this [__] and I'm
like
what is going on then I heard the dude
that the old dude that created AI
someone this is not safe because the AIS
got their own minds and these
[__] gonna start doing their
own [__] I'm like is we in a [__]
movie right now what
the [__] man so do I need to invest in
the AI so I can have one with me up like
do y'all know [__] what the [__]
yeah actually pretty based opinion there
I have to say respect all right next
topic a bit related to it but there has
been a memo leaked a Google internal
memo that is titled we have no remote
and neither does open AI the memo
details and the website here claims to
have verified its origin so I'm just
gonna believe that for now the memo
details essentially the rise of Open
Source models especially models like
llama and just how prolific the
community becomes when they get access
to an open source model like this for
example though Laura like low rank
adapters being super useful making it
very cheap to fine-tune these big models
into something useful and the memo
argues that open source development will
be able to catch up in many ways with
the big companies and therefore a moat
if you don't know a moat is like is in
startup World emote is a position room
that is defendable against incursions
against your competition so if you have
a moat it means that a competitor can't
easily sort of reach you and the memo
argues that Google has no modes and
neither does open Ai and it goes into a
little bit of stuff we could have seen
it coming what we missed and so on
saying retraining models from scratch is
the hard part but once a big model is
out like llama then it can be worked
with really easily with for example
Laura updates are very cheap to produce
at around a hundred dollars a piece also
saying data quality scales better than
date to size which is obviously great to
hear given we do projects like open
Assistant that's absolutely fantastic
directly competing with open source is a
losing proposition and also commenting a
bit about the fact that individuals are
not constrained by licenses to the same
degree as corporations which is true
they say this will inevitably change as
truly open models get better not like
the Llama models as you may know have
this stupid non-compete license and many
of the other models like models coming
out of hugging face have these even
stupider actually less stupid open rail
license but still stupid we are waiting
for models for people who actually make
things open source and at that point I'm
very convinced the community will do
great things with it and a lot of
businesses can be built on open source
models as they are built right now on
open source software so there's a call
in this memo to let open source work for
us which has been a give and take in the
tech industry that large companies
support open source development but then
also obviously profit from the results
of it and the memo calls a little bit in
to the direction of that saying owning
the ecosystem might be a big part of
what makes the profit maximal for a
company and Google has been doing that
with things like Android but also with
things like tensorflow and stuff like
that so what do we make of a leaked
Google memo that essentially admits
they're gonna lose Auto open source and
so does open AI I think it's important
to say that it's not official
communication right anyone at a company
can write a memo and then sort of
circulate it that's just common practice
in these companies it's the employees
freedom to express their opinion and to
gather insights from around the company
it must not mean that this is the
official Google position or this is even
true right read it and estimate yourself
how good the arguments of this are but
you can rest assure them I'm very sure
this is internally not everyone agrees
with this this may be debated it may be
just a person writing down sort of
purposefully let's say extreme position
to sort of see what happens to what can
we make if we sort of make this argument
what counter arguments are there and so
on anyone can write a memo it can be
circulated people can give their opinion
so while this can absolutely be a true
Google memo all it means is that at
least one person in the company has
written this but what's more beautiful
is the memes oh my God the memes stop
molting can you just stop saying mode
emotes is this moat had ears to monetize
llms no mode mode it's over Anakin I
have the 65k context you underestimate
my moat anyway I hope you've all found
your modes because open AI may have no
modes but they have a sharply decreasing
bank account losing over 550 million
dollars over half a billion dollars as
it developed chat GPT that's what the
information right saying Open the Eyes
losses double to around 550 million US
Dollars last year as it developed chat
GPT and hired key employees from Google
according to three people with knowledge
of the startup's financials so pretty
crazy I mean you could have guessed that
like one or two of these millions would
go into getting a mode or two but they
apparently blew it all on chat GPT and
Google employees but we didn't have to
wait long for Google's reaction to chat
GPT as it now changed its AI strategy
Google has been along one of the most
prolific Publishers of academic papers
if you go to any machine learning
conference like nurips or icml Google
will always be at the top of the
organizations who publish the most
papers at these conferences and that was
even before they merged with deepmind oh
yeah Google brain merged with deepmind
that's a piece of news that I haven't
even in here that happened but even
before that Google was already super
prolific and so was deepmind and
together they would be an absolute
Juggernaut of publishing papers at
conferences however Google has now
changed its tune so as openai became
more closed focusing more and more on
developing product and their API and
releasing that joke of a paper slash
technical report on gpt4 is becoming
more and more clear that Jeff Hinton was
certainly right in one regard namely the
big Tech Giants are locked in into war
mode so Google here changed its strategy
the article here in the Washington Post
says the launch of open ai's
groundbreaking chat GPT three months
earlier had changed things the San
Francisco startup kept up with Google by
reading the team's scientific papers
lean said in the quarterly meeting for
the company's research division indeed
Transformers a foundational part of the
latest AI Tech and the T in chat GPT
originated in a Google study I'll first
go to the conclusion the conclusion is
Google researchers now first have to get
their stuff into products and then maybe
they can publish if they get approval
for it whereas before they could just
they could publish they were encouraged
to publish and then later they would see
whether and how that might go into a
product so Google Now more closed up in
more product focused however saying that
like open AI red Transformers paper and
that's why that's why I'm not sure I'm
really not that that's a bit far that's
a tiny bit far-fetched there definitely
the case that if you make everything
open it's easier to reproduce what
you've done also on the other hand
um no I mean the interesting thing is
how this is actually going to affect the
world of researchers Google and the
other companies have been publishing so
much I believe as a strategy to hire a
lot of these people because a lot of
researchers they wanna they get out of
University and they have the choice they
want to go academic path do I want to go
industry path and if you promise them
hey with us you can come and you can do
research and you can even publish it
right this is very attractive for
researchers to go there on top of that
they get like a giant salary and free
food but they do also get the publish
papers and a lot of them want that first
and foremost because they believe in in
research and second also because it
attaches their own name to something out
there so rather than it being in a
product somewhere where their name might
be listed not at all they'll be authors
on papers and that will increase their
chances of a future stuff that's going
to be interesting to see what these
people do when that's no longer on the
table when it's pretty clear once you go
into the big companies you will not get
to publish or at least for not for a
long time how's that going to affect
their hiring and firing at the moment
it's firing time anyway so maybe that
goes in concordance at the moment they
don't want more people and therefore
this is okay maybe once they want more
people again they'll open up the
publishing guidelines again although
it's not that easy and the effects are
probably longer term I don't know let me
know what you think how that's going to
affect the general landscape the fight
between the big companies is shaping
it's looking to be really interesting
speaking of open Ai and Google and
competitiveness Focus buyer has shared a
pretty remarkable clip of Ilya satskiver
of openai leadership commenting on why
do we keep things closed so I'm gonna
play the clip you know my view is that
the current level of capability is still
not that high where it will be the
safety consideration it will drive the
close close Source in the model this
kind of this kind of research
so in other words a claim that it goes
in phases right now it is indeed the
competitive phase so essentially saying
hey yeah we keep the stuff closed but
right now it's not because of safety
considerations because the capabilities
are not so strong right now that you
would need to do that due to safety
considerations by the way interesting to
see that this agreement within here but
instead right now it's because of the
competitive landscape yes I mean that's
what everyone knew that's unambiguously
confirming what we all knew but just
wanted to hear admitted openai has long
claimed that they keep things closed
because of safety considerations and
whatnot and it was always extremely
Shady so it's nice to somewhere here now
that that was all crap and they knew it
was crap and they simply said it so that
they have a fine excuse to keep things
for themselves until now when it's now
okay to be competitive and to keep
things closed in order to be competitive
so think of that going forward open AI
will just say whatever they need to in
order to stay competitive I mean not
that the other companies probably
wouldn't do that but it's still quite
remarkable because they were the first
one to keep models closed due to safety
considerations some like developers of
the early YOLO iterations refused to
work on more models due to safety
considerations but open air were the
first prominent ones to say uh no we'll
just keep these to ourselves because uh
you know you're you're they're too
dangerous for you plebs AI generated
images and text cannot be copyrighted
according to us copyright office this
light from a talk at UC Berkeley by
Pamela Samuelson and the reason why they
can't be copyrighted that's the policy
statement right here is because they
lack human authorship which is
entrenched in U.S copyright law a human
has to do something creative for
copyright to apply this is the case in
many countries around the world and
therefore the direct application of
copyright to AI generated works is not
given because they lack human authorship
what's also interesting when people
apply to register works that incorporate
AI generated text images or other
content they must identify parts that
are AI generated and disclaim authorship
of those parts it's pretty interesting
it's gonna get into a lot of gray areas
where it's like well what if I have
refined and isn't my selection process
also part of the creative process and
yada yada so all of these questions are
as of yet unclear but it is good to hear
this confirmed copyright needs human
authorship which also means what I've
said for a long time is that models very
probably are also not subject to
copyright because they've been generated
by an algorithm like an optimization
algorithm and therefore yeah the only
way to enforce any sort of lice license
on an AI model is through an active
contract where you actively make people
sign stuff before they get access to the
model rather than just shipping it with
like a GPL license or so and then
relying on the automatic application of
copyright also other news in
intellectual property there is a
trademark office trademark application
with this number that tries to trademark
the mark GPT the owner is open AI so
open AI is trying to trademark GPT now I
don't know enough about trademarks and
the trademark registration process to
tell you what any of this even means
right if they they're trying to
trademark the word GPT they have updated
their brand guidelines and they are
going after people who use GPT as part
of their thing whatever the thing is so
they certainly act as if they have a
trademark to that but also here on the
bottom says therefore you request is
hereby dismiss I don't know I I don't
know what it means I'll just tell you
that it exists okay next news star coder
is a model that comes out of the big
code project that is led by homingface
but is an open Community project to
train a 15 billion parameter large
language model with 8 000 tokens context
on source code in over 80 programming
languages and model and data are
available so this is pretty cool and
lots of congratulations and respect for
all the people having take part in this
I do have a small curl about this as you
may know here it says open source and
it's distinctively not open source you
know the good days of Open Source when
you need to agree to share your contact
information to access this model uh yeah
all the open source projects that also
where you have to accept the conditions
of the license to access its files and
contents absolutely open source like
every other open source project nothing
to see here because this is not licensed
as open source it's licensed via the
open rail license which is the so-called
responsible AI license
rant over red pajama is a project to
collect llama style data set and then
train on it they have just released uh 3
billion and seven billion models they
are even instruction tune and chat
models so very cool definitely follow
the red pajama project it's an
absolutely amazing project and the
models are open source I think let's see
yeah look at that license Apache how
hard is that how hard is it is the world
going down because this exists no it's
only gonna get better another project
that builds on the red pajama data set
is open Llama which is also an open
reproduction of llama and that loss just
looks I mean there's no sharp drop so
AGI hasn't been reached yet but so far
the metrics look really good and they
are reportedly better than equally sized
model like the 7B model is better than a
7B pythia model because it's been
trained on more data and that's exactly
the effect we're looking for in llama
style training so very excited to see
what comes out of these efforts and
obviously every single person outside of
openai is gonna profit that probably
even open AI employees are gonna profit
heavily from open source models being
fully open source and fully available to
the public that being said Mosaic
releases
npt7b a new standard for open source
commercially usable llms this is a good
step into that direction Mosaic focuses
on rapid training rapid fine tuning very
efficient training of models and they
have used their own knowledge and tools
in order to produce these models the
models are 7 billion parameter models
which would have been huge a few years
ago but it's kind of small right now but
still they're trained for a long time
and most notably some of them have a 65
000 token context length now that is
certainly something very cool very cool
we've demonstrated Generations as long
as 40 8 000 tokens on a single node of a
100 gpus absolutely crazy and again
license Apache and the world is still
here YOLO Nas is a neural architecture
search over YOLO networks YOLO you only
look once is an object detector and YOLO
Nas is a project that uses architecture
search in order to determine the best
and fastest models this picture doesn't
do the model Justice the model is
extremely good so absolutely cool
weights are available under a
non-commercial license for now yeah try
it out Mojo is a new programming
language for all AI developers at least
the company modular claims so this comes
from very respectable sources notably
one of the creators is also the creator
of the llvm tool chain which Powers most
compilers for example of C plus plus and
other languages so what is mojo Mojo is
a superset of python so you can run all
python code in Mojo but if you add your
types always it allows it to compile it
faster not only compile it down to
binary code but also do so for various
AI accelerators so it's kind of like
cython meets Cuda meets xla or something
like this safe to say that this has the
ability to not only make your python
code a lot faster but also make
transferring stuff from different
accelerators probably a lot more easy
and also you can end file names in an
emoji so that that's a Mojo file the
company says the language is in very
early development and it's not open
sourced yet but it will be open sourced
in the future but it not being open
source for now keeps many people
currently from trying it out or from
switching over to it we'll see what
happens definitely very cool project to
look out for hacker prompt is a prompt
hacking competition there are various
stages here this is made by various
organizations in including
learnprompting.org which is a website
that kind of teaches you prompting and
it's not a course you don't you don't
have to pay money for it this is a
competition with a sizable Chunk in
prize money so if you want to have fun
prompting it's a weird world it's a
weird world where this is an actual
competition yeah there's cash prizes
there's extra prizes and so on could be
fun Nvidia releases Nemo guard rails
which is a system that keeps a check on
a large language model so in Nemo
guardrails you can Define different
things different conversation flows and
so on and then propose what they call
guard rails for for topics for safety
considerations and for security so for
example if you don't want your friendly
company chat bot to all of a sudden
start talking about I don't know illegal
substances or or insult the customer or
anything like this a topical guard rails
could be interesting for you the tools
available open source and as far as I
understand it works with any large
language model in the background
whichever one you want to do the way it
works is that there is an engine
converting the input into a canonical
form in the canonical form you can
Define your guard rails like what you
want to happen if certain things happen
that's very much kind of a programmatic
form then you have flow execution which
is maybe deny or maybe rephrase or do
anything that you want I guess and in
the end you generate the output from
that so there's GitHub wrap up check it
out lmql is a programming language for
language model interaction this is ql is
to give you a hint that it is similar to
a query language like SQL or graphql or
I don't know any other qls but lmql
language model query language lets you
express things that you would like to
know from a language model for example
here is the tell a joke prompt or input
query query it's called the query so you
input your prompt but then you can can
Define these variables this is a whole
variable this is where you would like
the language model to put something
right then here this is followed by a
variable called the punch line so these
are variables that you define so this
would be your prompt you say which model
and you can specify some where Clauses
for example I want the joke to be
smaller than 120 tokens or characters
like some stopping Criterium and so on
so lmql will take all of this and
interact with the language model for you
in this case for example make the
language model fill these whole
variables right here and you can see the
output of the model is this and then
lmql will be able to read these
variables here out of the response
another one is here for example
sentiment classification so here is a
review we had a great stay hiking in the
mountains was fabulous yada yada
question is the underlying sentiment of
this review what is the underlying
sentiment of this review and why and
then there's a whole variable called
analysis and then then it says based on
this the overall sentiment of the
message can be considered to be and
another whole variable and here in the
distribution Clause you can say actually
this classification whole variable it
can only be one of these things right
here so you can strain the model at that
particular point lmql will then go and
ask the model make sure that this here
is in fact one of the tokens where that
you have specified right here or one of
the sequences all in all this saves you
a lot of grunt work from sort of having
to query the model at various points
look at the logins do something with the
log it's stop buff there are certain
point force it to do something and so on
so this is very cool and it can be
combined with other tools such as long
chain or or other things that you may
know I I don't know I just know line
chain and this AI makes pandas data
frames conversational it adds generative
artificial intelligence capabilities to
pandas what you can do with this is
something like this you have a data
frame right here country gdp's happiness
and you can ask something like which are
the five happiest countries and it'll
give you an output you can also make
plots and stuff with that so in the
background this also does the the pandas
operations for you and gives you the
results this is is potentially pretty
pretty cool if this is pushed a bit
further maybe with some tooling
assistance and so on I'm not sure how
the tools of the future are gonna look
like but I definitely see something like
this being extremely useful and making
data analysis more accessible to people
who also don't know programming laminize
company and also an llm engine for
rapidly customizing models so lamini
gives you open source tools to rapidly
customize a model like do fine tuning do
rlhf and so on and they also on top of
that offer a service where they manage
all of that for you pretty cool
combination we see more and more
startups operate in this give you
something open source and then offer a
service on top way yeah it's very cool
benefits a lot of people deep Floyd is a
group at stability and they have
released a model called if that is in
many ways really really really good text
to image model especially it handles for
example text very well it looks very
good and that's because the model it
operates in pixel space not in Hidden
token space so things like stable
diffusion they operate in this latent
token space so you have like some vqa
encoder and then you have the latent
tokens and that's where the diffusion
process runs whereas with if the
diffusion process runs directly on
pixels so the image is generated in 64
by 64 and then has two sequences of up
sampling to make it actually look
bearable and not only bearable but it
looks really good after that those two
up sampling steps it's also cool that
we're still seeing different approaches
to the fusion models so I'm in latent
space summon pixels and so on yeah you
can check this out on hugging face you
can try it and you can download it also
this as far as I understand
non-commercial for now but they do claim
it's going to be fully commercially like
permissively licensed in the future for
now I only believe it once I see it but
will like to believe them the Brahma
Foundation has released shimmy which is
an API compatibility tool for converting
popular external RL environments to the
gymnasium and petting Zoo's apis this is
really important especially for
reinforcement learning where the details
of the environment can be quite
overwhelming and standard environments
such as gymnasium formerly open AI gym
they're quite nice to work with because
it decouples the development of the
reinforcement learning algorithm with
the any intricacies of the environment
so it's very cool that the ferama
foundation spends effort into making
things even more compatible into
bringing external environments into the
standard environments or making them
compatible by the shimmy Library go here
releases a blog post called the
embedding archives millions of Wikipedia
article embeddings in many languages
releasing a subset of Wikipedia embedded
using their embedding models yeah you
can now just download these embeddings
which is really cool Wikipedia is a big
Corpus of very high quality this can
serve as the basis for a lot of
applications researchers at meta and
other places release a cookbook on
self-supervised learning with learnings
that they have on self-supervised
learning obviously people at meta have
been among the ones pushing most into
getting ever better techniques for
self-supervised Learning and it's very
cool to see that they're now compiling
this and sharing what they've learned in
a condensed form for you to consume at
once very cool H2O GPT aims to be the
best open source GPT led by H2O AI these
are models you can try them they have 20
billion parameter models 12 billion
parameter models and even 30 billion
parameter models they also have models
that are already fine-tuned on for
example open Assistant data and also
those you can just try it on hung face
on top of that they release llm Studio
which is a framework for no code
fine-tuning state-of-the-art large
language models very cool meta releases
a giant data set of annotated drawings
so these drawings they will have
annotation points like where is the hand
where is the head and so on and allow
things like this to be done very cool
This research has been out earlier and
now they're releasing the data set of
nearly 180
000 annotated amateur drawings to help
other AI researchers and creators to
innovate further excellent thank you
very much camel is a project and a paper
for studying language I guess by letting
language models communicate with each
other it's a very unique approach but if
they make these things role play and
talk to each other they can study things
about them I say this here because code
and models are both available so if you
are interested in that kind of stuff
then feel free to check it out
Aya is another model that does text to
image paella has updated their model to
a new version that is now even better
Paya is itself claiming to not be the
best text image model but to be the
simplest in terms of inference code and
that's actually quite true so this here
is the full code that's needed to sample
from the model and as you can see it's
very easy to keep an overview so another
cool model to check out and also notably
it's not a Transformer it's a con net
excellent Sebastian rushka releases a
blog post called fine tuning large
language models and it's quite good it's
an introduction to the core ideas and
approaches so if you are just in
amazement how people people can adapt
and tune all of these models like llama
models even though they're really big
this blog post is certainly a good place
for you in general Sebastian's blog is a
very good resource to learn about modern
things in deep learning pick a pick is
an app for collecting human feedback on
AI generated images the code is
available so you can run this locally if
you have any sort of images AI generated
images for humans to rate this might be
a good place for you in addition they do
release a data set images data set
rankings data set where people have
already come and rated AI generated
images excellent so they say help us in
creating the largest publicly available
human feedback or text to image data set
if you're in the mood to rate an image
or two that's where you go snorkel AI is
holding a conference there is a virtual
event June 7th through 8th and you get
the chance to present your poster there
there is a poster competition I'm
telling you this because the the
conference is free and the poster
competition you can win prizes so if you
have a poster that you would like to
publish but you don't want to go to all
the way to an academic conference that
costs like a thousand bucks in entry fee
and you have to fly somewhere this might
be an excellent alternative and if
you're in the competition there's prizes
I found this to be funny if you search
in Amazon for the string as an AI
language model you'll feel you'll like
find find stuff like reviews and
comments where people just copy paste it
from chat GPT and look at this the
weirdest part is this here it's a book
one paragraph starts with as an AI
language model I can't so people are
writing books using chat GPT and then
trying to sell them on Amazon I've had a
bunch of people ask me this and saying
like oh look I made a book using chatin
it was so fast and I'm like yo why would
why would someone if they look for this
information that's in your book why
wouldn't they just go to chat GPT I
huh deepmind has a new research paper
out about Robo soccer these guys are
just so cute but also the capabilities
here are quite astounding because these
are end-to-end reinforcement learned and
that's quite crazy because movement like
this we're used to from like Boston
Dynamics and so on but I believe they
hard code like every single movement and
they have a tight control algorithms
where here I'm not sure entirely which
part is all reinforcement learned they
exhibit very very different and very
adaptive Behavior I've recently visited
Lab at eth also doing Robo soccer a
different discipline than this one which
I'll also hopefully share soon and
that's also really really interesting so
the paper is called learning agile
soccer skills for bipedal robot with
deep reinforcement learning and here's a
video of of like someone pushing over
the robots and I'm like don't do that
don't do that if Jeff Hinton is right
that thing you'll be the first person no
you'll be the first person to get
they'll remember they'll remember
forever they have ah no how long does a
hard disk store stuff you you better
hide for longer than that anyway thank
you so much for watching this was ml
news thank you for being here if you do
have a moat please like this video and
tell your friends about it so I'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
foreign